[Musique]
en France depuis la crise sanitaire un
phénomène inquiète de plus en plus les
autorités y a-t-il de plus en plus de
dérives sectaires en France selon la
mission interministérielle de vigilance
et de lutte contre les dérives sectaires
les signalements récemment explosé plus
de 4000 l'an dernier soit une hausse de
33 %
elle a cherché des réponses spirituelles
c'est la multiplication des gourous 2.0
sur Internet qui cible particulièrement
les jeunes des individus autonomes
automatisés thérapeutes coach conseil
experts lutter contre tous ces
phénomènes le gouvernement fait
aujourd'hui polémique avec son plan
d'action contre le complotisme et les
dérives sectaires la ministre s'explique
dans TPMP
merci madame la secrétaire d'État Sonia
bacs d'être avec nous bonjour Merci
alors déjà vous on fait pas de politique
mais on la kiffe
on va pas se mentir c'est vrai qu'à
chaque fois vous faites des apparitions
on se dit on a envie d'être son copain
et en plus vous vous occupez d'un truc
que vous connaissez vous n'êtes pas là
par hasard merci d'être là ça vous êtes
content d'être là oui je suis très
content d'être là je vous présente
Matthieu Delormeau
musculation
alors on voulait d'abord revenir on
voulait d'abord revenir sur votre
parcours personnel qui est incroyable
parce que c'est très lié à votre
fonction de lutte contre les dérives
sectaires vous avez passé votre enfance
auprès de votre mère surtout log
et vous avez vu de très près ce qui
était l'embrigadement sectaire et ça
c'est important de le dire à noter les
spectateurs parce que aujourd'hui vous
occupez de ça c'est important de savoir
de quoi on parle oui effectivement c'est
vrai que j'avais neuf ans quand ma mère
est rentrée en Scientologie rentrer tout
simplement par un test de personnalité
sur un trottoir en vous pose des
questions un peu comme des tests qu'il y
a dans les les magazines féminins et
puis à la fin on vous dit vous avez tel
problème on peut vous aider et c'est le
c'est le point d'entrée c'est d'ailleurs
le point d'entrée beaucoup de
d'organisation sectaire soit là c'était
sur le trottoir maintenant il y a les
réseaux sociaux qui font la même chose
et c'est vrai que c'est le billet
d'entrée puis après je suis elle est
rentré j'ai vu l'emprise dont elle a été
victime et puis la difficulté d'en
sortir alors c'est vrai que c'est fou
c'est bizarre ça parle juste d'un test
de personnalité ça c'était incroyable
quand je me suis plongé là dedans
l'embrigadement se fait ensuite petit à
petit comme vous l'avez dit vous même
vous auriez pu être embrigadé ou pas du
tout oui parce que enfin je crois que
quand on est enfant quand on a 9 ans et
que ses parents nous disent ben en fait
ça va être bien je crois qu'on a des
difficultés à faire avoir des choses on
se dit pas que nos parents nous emmènent
dans un truc complètement farfelu ma
mère s'est retrouvée directrice de ce
qui s'appelait l'école de l'éveil
l'école scientologue qui était à Paris
et depuis fermé et depuis qui a été
fermé par par l'État 2 ans après sa
création j'ai été là-dedans et c'est
vrai que alors les modalités
pédagogiques si on peut appeler ça comme
ça est un peu particulier mais quand on
est gamin on se rend pas compte on se
rend pas compte quand c'est ses parents
qui nous emmènent là-dedans quand en
plus ma mère était directrice de l'école
ça ça me paraissait normal alors c'est
quoi la Scientologie exactement comment
ça marche la Scientologie c'est un c'est
un gourou qui s'appelait el ronub hard
qui a qui en fait créé une un certain
nombre de théories et notamment le fait
que on accumule des images négatives à
l'intérieur de soi dans quelque chose
qui s'appelle un Bank et en fait la
Scientologie est là pour vous vider les
images négatives et devenir une âme plus
pure je résume évidemment parce que ça
est très compliqué mais quand on quand
on vous présente les choses comme ça
personne ne rentre parce qu'on se dit
non mais faut quand même mettre un peu
naïf pour rentrer et et je crois qu'il
faut jamais juger parce qu'il y a
vraiment l'ambassadeur c'est Tom Cruise
moi je connais le département tout le
monde à tous les téléspectateurs qui
nous regardent doivent se dire ah oui
c'est le truc de Tom Cruise exactement
Tom Cruise il a il est rentré là-dedans
aussi oui parce que parce que en fait le
problème c'est on vous dit pas au départ
on va vous faire de vous une âme pure
parce que sinon vous rentrez pas on vous
dit non mais on va vous former vous
allez vous avez un problème ma mère
c'était le divorce de mes parents on va
vous aider à traverser cette épreuve là
on va vous aider elle était enseignante
aussi à mieux apprendre à vos élèves
bref on vous donne tout un tas d'outils
qui en fait petit à petit vous font
rentrer dedans on change votre
vocabulaire on change votre façon de
penser et petit à petit en fait vous
êtes plus en zone de confort à
l'intérieur du de l'organisme qu'à
l'extérieur et c'est ça le phénomène
d'emprise c'est que petit à petit et
puis après on vous inculque des idées
accessoirement on vous fait payer un peu
parce que c'est quand même le principe
vous comment vous êtes sortis de tout ça
vous
alors moi je suis sortie parce que
d'abord j'ai eu une première alerte
encore une fois quand c'est ses parents
je pense que c'est difficile d'être
conscient de la situation donc moi
j'avais une caméra quand l'école de
scientologue à fermer je me suis
retrouvé dans le public et j'ai une
petite camarade tout simplement qui en
voyant le courrier que j'allais chercher
dans ma boîte aux lettres a vu le logo
de l'Église de Scientologie elle m'a dit
mais est-ce que tu sais que c'est une
secte j'avais jamais entendu là ce mot
ce mot-là de ma vie c'est quoi une secte
est-ce que tu peux m'expliquer et elle a
commencé à me donner des infos et là
finalement la la la conscience a
commencé en se disant mais effectivement
qu'est-ce que c'est à chercher etc et
puis au final je suis partie de manière
un peu brutale parce que ma mère m'a
envoyé à l'église de scientologie à
Londres pour parce que je commençais à
me rebeller et je suis parti et je suis
allée rejoindre mon père qui est en
Nouvelle-Calédonie et votre mère elle a
continué elle a continué toute sa vie je
voulais vraiment que vous en parliez ce
soir parce que c'est important aussi de
connaître votre parcours parce que
aujourd'hui vous êtes au cœur de
l'actualité avec ce que vous êtes en
train de lancer avec le gouvernement et
c'est vrai que c'était important pour
noter les spectateurs aussi de montrer
n'est pas là par hasard que vous étiez
vraiment au coeur du dispositif sectaire
dispositifs sectaires et votre histoire
est complètement incroyable c'est fou
alors justement on va en parler les
signalements de dérive sectaire
augmentent apparemment
énormément puis c'est ces derniers mois
ces dernières années et c'est pour ça
que vous avez vous avez décidé de lancer
un plomb voilà pour pour endiguer tout
ça alors racontez-nous oui en fait
effectivement on a un rapport qui vient
de sortir les chiffres sont affichés à
une augmentation importante et puis une
évolution au-delà de l'augmentation une
évolution des des types et des modalités
d'entrée dans les dérives sectaires avec
notamment toute la partie
naturopathe bien-être etc qui en fait
font rentrer alors depuis le covid ça
c'est énormément accentué d'une part par
l'enfermement d'autre part par sans
doute la remise en cause du fait
scientifique et puis peut-être la
recherche d'une forme de bien-être un
peu différent et donc en fait on a tout
un tas de de de Guru qui qui s'invente
en vous disant que vous allez aller
beaucoup mieux avec tel jus de légumes
je voyais il y a beaucoup de femmes qui
souffrent d'endométriose c'est quelque
chose qui les fait énormément souffrir
et il y a tout un tas de charlatans
autour de ça et quand on a un problème
comme ça quand on a une faille forte
quand on a une vulnérabilité quelqu'un
arrive en vous disant on va vous soigner
de votre cancer votre maladie votre peu
importe quoi vous vous espérez vous avez
un espoir et et on vous fait rentrer
alors justement on a un extrait qui qui
voilà regardez illustre ça globalement
quand tu prends une chimiothérapie tu
finis comme une poupée Jivaro tu perds
tes dents tu perds tes cheveux tu
deviens tout fripé globalement tu
injecte de la mort dans les veines la
chimiothérapie n'importe quelle chose
c'est 50000 euros la personne qui va la
vendre le diabète n'est pas un problème
actuellement la politique qui vise à
surajouter de l'insuline vous conduit
directement à la mort personnellement je
prendrai mon enfant j'irai me planquer
pour échapper à ce système qui veut
simplement faire des cobayes qui veut
simplement utiliser des traitements à 50
000 euros sur des gamins qui sont
débilitants à vie jamais aucun
médicament symptomatique ne vous
soignera
voilà donc c'est vrai que là dessus je
trouve que c'est très important à
vraiment de d'agir vite parce que c'est
vrai qu'on voit de tout sur les réseaux
sociaux
immédiates tout ça c'est vrai qu'on voit
des trucs incroyables et ça ça c'est pas
possible il faut agir vite parce que
c'est vrai qu'il y a des gens chaque
fois qu'ils ont quelque chose ils vont
sur les réseaux ils disent bah tiens on
m'a dit ça on m'a dit de faire ça on m'a
dit de faire ci et c'est pour la santé
ça peut être dramatique et je peux vous
dire ça peut être encore plus grave que
ce que vous avez plein de gens parfois
ils ont des petits trucs et regarde un
truc sur le net ils le font et derrière
ça aggrave le cas encore plus que ce que
ça doit être alors aujourd'hui
ce qui dérange un petit peu j'ai vu sur
les réseaux etc c'est les dérives
sectaires et surtout les dérives
complotistes comment savoir
qu'une prise d'opposition sur les
réseaux sociaux et complotiste comment
faire le distinguer entre un avis et un
complot ce qui est très important
d'abord c'est que chacun a le droit de
croire dans ce qu'il veut c'est le
principe c'est la liberté d'opinion vous
avez envie de croire que on va être
envahi par les martiens la semaine
prochaine vous avez le droit de le
croire si vous avez envie de croire que
les jus de légumes ça fait du bien vous
avez le droit de croire dans ce que vous
voulez c'est le principe de base le
complotisme c'est en fait l'utilisation
de toute une série de théories non
prouvées qui en fait génère une forme de
séparatisme de de ce qui en fait
vérifier c'est à dire qu'en fait petit à
petit on a on impose une pensée on met
une pensée qui finalement sépare de la
société qui dit finalement le fait
scientifique lui il vaut rien c'est ce
que vous avez vu avec avec casasnova qui
a été montré là alors la chimiothérapie
la radiothérapie ça soigne le cancer
c'est prouvé ça soigne pas tous les
cancers ça soigne pas de manière
systématique c'est aussi bien dans sa
vie de voir des jus de légumes il y a
pas de problème mais simplement les jus
de légumes ça n'a jamais soigné aucun
cancer et c'est là en fait la différence
entre le complotisme et le fait de
croire dans ce qu'on veut c'est
finalement de de de faire croire des
choses complètement anti-système et de
et finalement d'amener à ce que à ce
qu'on croit que le système est mis en
place pour nous amener à du mensonge que
que tout est organisé
là on le voit parce que c'est vrai que
c'est ça qui est compliqué c'est que là
la frontière elle est compliquée et
c'est vrai que moi l'exemple que j'ai
c'est par rapport bien entendu on parle
de la vaccination par exemple voilà le
le vaccin contre le covid et c'est
contre la covid c'est vrai que ça à mon
avis c'est là aussi qu'on a vu que des
vidéos alors on sait plus qui croient
moi j'ai vu plein de vidéos de
youtubeurs qui disaient ça qui disait on
a donné la parole il y a plein de gens
ici on le dit on dit la vérité comment
se dire on donne la parole à un
complotiste on donne la parole à
quelqu'un qui a une idée différente
quelle est la différence c'est ça
l'histoire est-ce que c'est ça qui est
important la différence c'est le le la
véracité du fait scientifique je vais
vous prendre je veux pas débattre sur la
question de la vaccination parce que je
pense qu'on en finirait pas mais on a eu
récemment une campagne d'affichage à
Toulouse avec des affiches qui disaient
un une dose sur 100 à amené à des
accidents cardiovas cardiovasculaires en
France on a eu 150 millions de doses
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on a 1,5 millions
de Français qui ont eu des accidents
cardiovasculaires la réponse est non
donc le fait scientifique avéré c'est
que non on n'a pas une dose sur 100 qui
a donné lieu à des accidents
cardiovasculaires ça c'est le fait
scientifique et je pense que c'est sur
ça qu'il faut se baser et c'est là la
différence entre la science n'est pas
une croyance la science c'est des choses
qui sont prouvées c'est des choses qui
sont on a des scientifiques qui qui font
des des
encore une fois les faits les croyances
on a le droit de croire dans ce qu'on
veut on a le droit de faire ce qu'on
veut avec son corps avec le problème
c'est de considérer que c'est un fait
que c'est un fait scientifique à la même
hauteur qu'une croyance alors Béatrice
qui est là qui est bout depuis tout à
l'heure
voilà madame bonjour
je trouve que vous faites l'amalgame de
tout on a montré un exemple d'un
charlatan caricatural mais vous avez
l'air de mettre tous les naturopathes ou
toutes les médecines parallèles dans le
même panier moi par exemple j'ai fait de
l'acupuncture à un moment donné de ma
vie pour une pathologie qui n'était pas
soignable par la médecine traditionnelle
connaissance
elle a jamais eu remis en cause
parce que c'est un sujet qui peut amener
à des dérives des dérives de liberté de
penser d'expression terrible c'est à
dire que vous en prenant le combat
contre les dérives sectaires et les
charlatans qui sont tout à fait c'est un
combat tout à fait légitime mais ça sur
ça je vous rejoins complètement vous
passez sous ce parapluie le les
histoires de complotisme et par exemple
avec le covid on a vu des fake news qui
étaient traités de complotisme comme par
exemple les problèmes de cycle suite au
vaccin etc qui sont maintenant des vrais
news donc il y a des gens qui ont été
censurés sur les plateformes qui ont été
censurées dans les médias il y a des
médecins donc on a bousillé la carrière
qui ont ensuite été blanchies et dont on
n'a pas parlé alors on en parle pour les
leurs bousiller leur carrière mais on
parle pas quand ils ont été blanchis
je vous aime beaucoup ici on a reçu
plein de gens qui étaient contre le
vaccin ou pour le vaccin on a tout reçu
ici
vous les êtes en train excusez-moi de
vous dire ça vous êtes en train de tout
mélanger excusez
cette partie dans un combat qui n'est
pas celui de la secrétaire d'État ça n'a
rien à voir on parle pas du tout de ça
si on parlait de ça il faut comprendre
la maison d'abord science n'est pas
abouti c'est pas on ne connaît pas vous
parler de quoi force ne connaît pas tout
et ce qui peut paraître complotiste
aujourd'hui peut-être vrai demain
ce n'est pas possible
elle a dit que la frontière était très
contraignée et très voilà et que c'était
c'était dur de oui mais c'est pas ça là
moi
j'ai vu des choses circuler et je lis
moi sur le vaccin sur la personne tout
ça et je me suis interrogé il y a plein
de gens qui s'interrogent les gens qui
s'interrogent et moi ils seront toujours
les bienvenus ici et je les ai déjà dit
j'ai fait revenir plein de gens qui
s'interrogeaient et on a été les
premiers à s'interroger ici
on va continuer à s'interroger on va
continuer à s'interroger là sur ces gens
la différence entre est-ce qu'on les
est-ce qu'on les considère comme les
complotistes
du covid les opinions et enfin il y a
pas de souci je pense que c'est la c'est
aussi la force de la de la France et de
démocratie donc vraiment il y a pas de
sujet la nuance elle se passe quand il y
a mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
c'est ça en fait oui
là-dessus
c'est très important votre président a
dit notre président a dit que et des
ministres ont affirmé sur des plateaux
télé que les soignants non vaccinés
mettez la vie d'autrui
justement ce que vous dites je peux vous
dire on peut l'entendre mais ça n'est
pas du tout le débat
c'est pas du tout
on en parlera peut-être de ça mais là de
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui c'est
exactement ça
je mélange le fait politique
par exemple c'est Jean-Marie Bigard qui
dit que l'on septembre n'a pas existé
que voilà voilà
le complotisme c'est dire que l'incendie
de Notre-Dame de Paris a été organisée
par Macron ça c'est exactement donc il
faut lutter contre ça le complotisme
c'est dire par exemple que avec les
tests PCR on nous injecte une micro puce
ça c'est du complotisme ou de nous dire
que pendant la crise du covid les
hôpitaux étaient vides ça c'est du
complot tu m'as traité de complotiste je
n'ai jamais dit tout ce que tu viens de
dire ni bien loin donc ça veut dire que
à ce moment là pendant la crise
sanitaire il y a eu un débat sur le
complotisme
et je crois qu'on est d'accord
ok
le 11 septembre
s'il vous plaît pas tous en
insupportable pour vous on va en parler
dans un instant parce que Fabrice il
sera avec nous est-ce que Fabrice
division est-ce que Fabrice division a
eu des des propos complotistes écoutez
j'ai pas j'ai pas à juger mais par
contre par contre pour reprendre ce que
disait Géraldine là où c'est inquiétant
c'est que sur les tests complotistes
qu'elle a qu'elle a évoqué certaines là
et d'autres on a fait il y a une étude
qui a été faite sur un panel de Français
qui prouve que 21% des Français sont
croit dans 5 de ces thèses là sur 10 et
on a pris des choses le le le le le la
mort de Lady Di a été organisée c'est un
crime etc etc et donc on a quand même
20% plus de 20 % des Français près de
30% quand il s'agit des moins de 24 ans
qui croit dans dans cet état
je vous jure et moi la mort de Lydie je
sais pas voilà il y a plein de gens qui
en parle tout ça on sait pas nous dans
nous le grand public voilà moi je suis
pas dans le truc je m'interroge
exactement
la mort de Lady c'est le meilleur
exemple de complotisme c'est le 11
septembre
pour moi ça c'est voilà c'est vraiment
le type
c'est le négationnisme en faitisme
pousse à l'extrême c'est les champs à
gaz qui n'empêchait exactement voilà
c'est exactement c'est l'exemple numéro
1 félicite de lutter contre ça après
après et moi je le dis et je suis
content que la secrétaire d'État lui dit
ici il faut se poser des questions et
continuer à vous poser des questions
continuera à recevoir ceux qui se posent
des questions et ceux qui posent des
questions pour remettre le débat
c'était pas possible
vous étiez le seul Cyril
je n'ai jamais eu et je le dis ici et
j'ai aucune et je le dis j'ai jamais de
pression et vous le savez je m'en suis
jamais caché vous dites oui je je parle
je vais parler avec le président de la
République voilà on a échangé sur plein
de choses notamment sur le vaccin je le
dis son vaccin il ne m'a et je le redis
ici jamais le président de Mahdi cy
n'invite pas à tel ou telle personne
Cyril lève le pied sur ça ou sur ça il
n'est jamais rentré là-dedans on a on a
évoqué une fois la vaccination et je lui
ai dit que je me posais des questions
voilà et il a essayé de trouver des
arguments pour me dire voilà pourquoi tu
n'aurais pas été posé mais je vous le
dis jamais on m'a dit n'invite pas telle
personne ou telle personne
si on te dit de pas inviter quelqu'un et
contre ma coup de pression tu vas le
dire donc le mec savent très bien
non mais jamais j'ai eu de pression
jamais
et colère voilà juste on parlait de ce
plan d'action contre le complotisme et
les dérives sectaires et surtout c'est
sur le complotisme c'est vrai qu'il y a
plein de gens qui se disent la frontière
elle est elle est minime et justement
madame la secrétaire d'État par exemple
quelqu'un qui dit voilà je suis je suis
n'importe quoi qui met un tweet voilà je
suis je suis allé me faire vacciner et
j'ai
j'ai l'impression que j'ai des symptômes
voilà et des symptômes bizarres c'est
quoi c'est son droit c'est son droit
d'accord très bien donc ça voilà et je
voudrais juste vous dire
dire vie contraire ça contribue à aider
à la cause parce que ça développe
l'esprit critique et ce qui manque
parfois c'est l'esprit critique ce qui
arrive aujourd'hui sur les réseaux
sociaux sans filtre c'est vérifier pas
vérifier ça arrive de la même manière
que le garde des sceaux
moi j'invite donc en fait je considère
que les personnes dont on parle c'est
des personnes qui réfléchissent qui sont
curieuses et qui remettent les choses en
question donc il y a certains antibactes
pour vous ce sont des complotistes c'est
ça par exemple mais vous me dites parce
que j'ai une petite liste par exemple
donc dans les antibactes il peut y avoir
des complotistes ok donc dans la
médecine naturelle il peut y avoir des
complotistes naturelles aussi mais il y
a des complotistes
non mais je veux dire
on a les antivax on a les anti 5G on a
les véganes même on a les Antilles Linky
on a les rebouteux les magnétiseurs
différents hors de ce système que vous
créez donc tous les gens qui se posent
des questions pour essayer un peu
d'aller sur les sur les limites parce
que les compositions je vous ai jamais
dit non je suis désolé quand vous dites
ça je vous ai dit qu'effectivement il y
avait des tests complotistes ça je dis
par Géraldine tout à l'heure
effectivement quand on invente un
contre-système en considérant que
tout a été organisé pour c'est normal de
machination par exemple il y a eu un
grand complot juif par exemple voilà il
y a ça dans les bras c'est complotiste
par exemple ça dérangeant qu'on dise
quand quelqu'un dit qu'il aille un
symptôme à la suite de la vaguement ça
c'était pas du complotisme
alors qu'en fait c'est en fait c'est un
fait donc là
là là on les fasse tout de suite on les
fasse tout de suite ça madame la
secrétaire d'État vous a dit que ça
c'était pas du compétit l'exemple de
Géraldine c'est du complotisme le grand
c'est en fait voilà
c'est pas parce que j'avais dit du tout
en fait donc voilà
attendez pas la musique rideau on fera
un rideau Guillaume ce qui est
intéressant dans ce que dit Delphine par
exemple c'est que c'est vrai que la
définition du complotisme on a
l'impression qu'elle s'est élargi Stark
avant c'était les théories complètement
farfelues pour justifier le fait qu'on
est dominé par une force au-dessus nul
donc la terre est plate michael Jackson
n'est pas mort le 11 septembre etc et
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que
certaines personnes qui ont juste des
pensées contraires à une sorte de pensée
unique sont taxés de complotistes donc
ma question c'est est-ce que c'est pas
une stratégie mais pas de votre part
parce que je trouve que votre initiative
est noble c'est pas une stratégie de
faire passer pour des fous ceux qui ont
une pensée différente pour les anéantir
par la pensée justement
en combat c'est c'est pas le complotisme
d'ailleurs c'est c'est le point d'entrée
vers les dérives sectaires c'est à dire
qu'en fait il y a des qui parlent biais
du complotisme parce qu'on leur fait
croire que il y a une vaste machination
du système excusez-moi entre les entre
guillemets qui va les amener à se faire
soigner avec de la chimiothérapie alors
qu'en fait ça soigne pas du tout ce qui
a expliqué le monsieur tout à l'heure ou
alors peu importe et en fait par ce
biais là on les fait rentrer dans des
organisations qui elles soient les
dépôts financièrement soit les mettre
sous emprise on a été ce matin visiter
le service de police judiciaire qui fait
les enquêtes il y a des viols enfin il y
a des trucs extrêmement graves qui se
passent à l'intérieur des organismes et
en fait c'est juste ça moi après encore
une fois je suis j'ai écrit un livre qui
s'appelle libre vous savez donc moi la
liberté c'est essentiel pour moi et la
liberté d'opinion en particulier donc
les gens croient ceux qui veulent la
problématique c'est que quand ça met en
danger les gens
puisque c'est quelqu'un qui va bientôt
être libre également
sentimentalement je parle de moi le seul
problème je suis totalement d'accord
avec vous et je suis anti complotiste le
seul problème c'est quand
malheureusement le gouvernement est pris
dans l'histoire je pense par exemple à
l'époque au sang contaminé ou là
effectivement là c'est c'est le
gouvernement qui se retrouve responsable
de ces théories complotistes parce
qu'elles les ont pendant très longtemps
ni avant finalement les accepter donc de
temps en temps vous avez été et c'est ce
qui fait en sorte que le gouvernement
aujourd'hui n'est pas toujours médiateur
aussi n'est pas toujours totalement
crédible aujourd'hui pour dire aux gens
quand on fait quelque chose faites-le
c'est pas du complotisme écoutez-nous
parce que vous avez quand même du des
tâches sur les mains c'est ça le
problème et le problème c'est qu'il faut
pas utiliser une exception pour faire
une généralité vous avez fait sans doute
des erreurs dans votre vie
c'est pas utilisé pour faire finalement
le bilan de tout ce que vous faites et
je pense que quand même malgré tout dans
ce qui est fait globalement dans ce qui
est
proposé etc les choses sont faites de
manière prouvée scientifique etc voilà
alors c'est vrai que vous disiez Mathieu
serrer qu'après c'est vraiment voilà
c'est ça il faut continuer à
s'interroger et ça va être très
compliqué de dire ça c'est complotiste
ça c'est une vidéo ça c'est voilà ça
c'est un point de vue ça c'est
complotiste c'est Gilles oui ce que je
voulais dire devant madame la secrétaire
d'État c'est que vous le savez très bien
et Cyril beaucoup de jeunes vous
regardent on citait tout à l'heure les
moins de 24 ans il y a en ce moment
notamment en Île-de-France une
recrudescence de gourous 2.0 qui se
basant sur des thèses des théories des
idées complotistes endoctrine les jeunes
c'est un danger majeur il y en a plein
j'ai discuté avec beaucoup il y en a des
dizaines récemment en Île-de-France
c'est très dangereux il faut dire aux
jeunes attention ils viennent vous
recruter ils sont très forts très
pervers ce sont des gens qui après vont
vous endoctriner il va y avoir des
dérives sexuelles il va y avoir des
dérives financières que les jeunes
fassent attention en ce moment et c'est
vraiment un appel par vous Cyril qu'il
faut passer il y a un immense danger en
ce moment derrière les idées
complotistes qui peuvent séduire il y a
vraiment des gourous qui appeler jeunes
et qui vont les réduire ensemble c'est
important
le résumé c'est ça le danger contre
lequel on va lutter parce que par le
biais d'un certain nombre de tests qui
sont assez accessibles et accessibles
assez séduisantes on se retrouve avec un
vrai danger et en particulier pour les
jeunes qui reçoivent toute l'information
sans filtre mais concrètement il y aura
un numéro vert comment ça va se passer
concrètement on fait des assises en
début d'année pour identifier toutes les
problématiques et tout ce qu'on doit
régler et mettre en place un plan
d'action comment comment on identifie
quelqu'un qui est sous emprise comment
on voit que tout simplement parce que
petit à petit c'est pas de sa famille
c'est pas il a des comportements
étranges il se il a il a un sentiment de
révélation ou d'un truc magique dont
chacun sait sur la musculation comme sur
le reste que ça que ça fonctionne pas
etc etc donc c'est comment comment on
sensibilise en amont esprit critique
comment on signale et puis derrière
est-ce qu'il y a des évolutions
législatives à faire pour pour aller
chercher les gourous 2.0